so to start out I just wanted to mention
we talk a lot about dogma
in the lab so we talked about dogma
right there's the central dogma which is
DNA information flows from DNA to RNA to
protein I'm gonna describe another dogma
if you will which is that life starts as
sort of a fertilized egg so you're get a
fertilized egg and this fertilized egg
which you see in the video up here
undergoes development and as part of
that development there is what is known
as differentiation where cells acquire
more specialized cell types so there's
development and differentiation and this
results in adult cell types that are
known as differentiated so that results
in differentiated / adult cell types
with specialized functions and you see
just a few of them up on the slide above
there are in fact thousands of different
sort of cell types that humans have but
the dogma at least up until fairly
recently in the past couple decades or
so or at least before 1960 1950s is that
this is unidirectional that you
basically the development goes in one
direction where you go from the
fertilized egg to the differentiated
adult cell types and so this state down
here the differentiated adult cell types
are fairly stable right
I mean if you look at your neighbor you
see they don't have muscle growing on
the outside of their bodies right their
skin cells taste skin cells and that is
a relatively stable state okay now last
week you learned about sort of a
contradiction to the central dogma which
is the behavior of retroviruses which
which have reverse transcriptase which
can sort of go backwards up this pathway
where you can get DNA from RNA okay and
today we're going to talk about how you
can sort of overcome sort of this
uni-directional path here and this is
going to be what we will call
reprogramming but first I want to talk
about this differentiation process
because it's important for us to
understand this before we get into the
reprogramming event and so the
fertilized egg is capable of producing
all of these different cell types okay
so the fertilized egg will be known as
totipotent meeting and has the potential
to form all cell types and in over
development this potency goes down such
that when cells differentiate into their
final adult form there's a much more
limited repertoire of cell types that
the cell can go into and one way of
thinking about this is that if you think
of this marble run here right the
totipotent state is right at the top
here right if I put a marble on the top
here it has the potential of going into
any of these three sort of different
fates okay so this is the toady
and state up at the top and you'll see
these marbles will be able to go into
any of these three different states here
okay but you see how that marble went
down on this path some marbles go down
in this path and so you can think of
cells going through development is sort
of getting funneled into these distinct
paths in in this case it's kind of
random but in development it relies on
signaling between cells and interaction
between cells and the multicellular
organism okay okay so as an example I
want to tell you about early mammalian
development in the differentiation of
cell types in the early mammalian embryo
okay so we start with an oocyte it's the
female gamete and the male gamete the
sperm so these can come together to form
the zygote if I draw a little circle in
the middle it's a nucleus okay in this
is I goat is totipotent and the embryo
undergoes cleavage divisions which I'll
show here you see how that zygote
divided into two cells now it's going to
divide into four and it'll keep dividing
until it's 16 probably so you get
cleavage divisions that generate more
than one cell you start with a single
cell the cleavage divisions give you
more than one cell and what you see up
here now is a stage known as the blast
of blastocyst or the blastula you can
see there's a hollow sort of inner
fluid-filled area here and you see their
cells around
that fluid-filled cavity and there's a
thickening on one side of the embryo
okay so I'm gonna draw that out here
sorry mine is a little flat up here
should be perfectly spherical okay and
there there's this thickening on one
side of the blastula which is a bunch of
cells that are kind of interior and on
the inside of the embryo
okay these cells on the interior are
known as the inner cell mass and these
cells are now restricted in what they
can become
these cells will become the embryo
proper okay so they'll become the cell
types that'll be a part of the fetus
this these cells on the outside are
known as the trophoblast cells and these
are these cells will form part of the
placenta the embryonic portion of the
placenta so they form part of the
placenta and they're important for this
embryo being able to implant into the
uterine wall okay so if we think about
this is the first example of
differentiation in the early mammalian
embryo B as you can see based on what I
said here
these cells are becoming restricted and
what they can become okay so this is
kind of like the first branch point in
differentiation so we get some more sort
of marbles going down here alright so
this would be the sort of stage right
before the blastula before
differentiation and you can see these
marbles when I let them they will have
it they will either go this way and
become one fate or they'll go the other
way and be sort of direct
down on another sort of potential fates
yep
there we go so this is the first sort of
branch point if you will in fake
determination for the mammalian embryo
and so this branch point here right is
different from this because once the
marble goes one way or the other it's
restricted in what fate it can become
okay so this is the so this these cells
here are not totipotent because they
can't form the trophoblast they can't
form the part of the placenta needed by
the embryo but they do form the embryo
proper so they are still capable of many
faiths and so these cells are known as
pluripotent which means capable of many
things okay and so a type of cell type
which I'm sure you've heard about is
called embryonic stem cells or ES cells
these ES cells are derived from the
inner cell mass okay so these would be
if they were taken out of the blastula
sorry this is called the blastula if
they're are taken from the blastula
and cultured in vitro that these would
be sort of embryonic stem cells that can
be propagated okay so and they form the
embryo proper right so these are
pluripotent stem cells that can
basically they are still capable of
forming sort of any of the cell types in
the embryo capable of forming
embryonic cell types
okay now let's look at the next slide so
this this branch point right this first
branch point sort of in development is
associated with changes in gene
expression okay so there are changes in
gene expression and you're seeing one up
on the slide above the slide above is a
fixed blastula and all of the nuclei and
the blastula are stained with green but
there's one gene that's stained in red
that's called act four and this is a
transcription factor that marks sort of
pluripotency and you can see how it's
expressed specifically in these cells of
the inner cell mass which are the what
the embryonic stem cells are derived
from okay so they're clearly changes in
gene expression and one question you
might have is whether or not these cells
that that are going to form the embryo
proper whether they have lost
information such that they're unable to
form the part of the placenta okay and
you can also ask this for an adult cell
right has an adult cell in your body
hasn't lost gene content such that it's
unable to make an entire organism okay
I'm gonna tell you the answer I want you
to think about what experiment would
allow you to sort of determine the
answer but I'm gonna tell you the answer
is that there is not a loss of gene
content but this differentiation process
is due to changes in gene expression for
the vast majority of our cell types okay
so let's say you wanted to determine
whether or not a differentiated cell had
lost some sort of capability to
regenerate an entire organism what might
be some type of experiment you could do
[Music]
[Music]
to see it alright great so Brett had two
really good points I think the first is
to try to sort of reproduce conditions
of pluripotency or you could even try to
reproduce conditions of totipotency
right in which case you'd want to sort
of like take the genetic material of the
somatic cell and sort of put it back in
this situation where its present sort of
in the cytoplasm of a zygote okay and
the other point that Brett's made is to
try to maybe like express something that
would induce this type of pluripotent
state if we knew exactly what the genes
were that sort of like create this
pluripotent state maybe we could just
Express those genes and regenerate sort
of a cell that sort of moves from like
way down here all the way up to the top
again okay and actually what Brett
suggested were the two experiments that
won these two folks the Nobel Prize in
2012 so in 2012 the Nobel Prize was
awarded jointly to Sir John Gurdon right
here
who incidentally has the best hair of
all Nobel laureates and also Shinya
Yamanaka okay and so these two folks
were awarded the Nobel Prize for being
able to show that mature differentiated
cells can be reprogrammed to be to
become pluripotent again okay which
basically gives us the conclusion that
there's not a loss of gene content
during the differentiation process and
the work from Yamanaka showed us
of all genes whose expression is
critical to induce this type of
reprogramming okay and their work
spanned from frogs so John Gurdon worked
on development of frogs specifically
xenakis Lavis which you've seen before
Shinya Yamanaka is work involved mice
and also human cell lines okay so I'm
going to tell you about their
experiments and how this sort of
demonstrated this conclusion here and
the first thing I want to show you is an
experiment which is very simple
conceptually technically it's very
complicated which is if you are able to
take a nucleus from an adult cell that's
differentiated could you get it to
change by introducing it back into the
egg cell or a zygote cell okay so this
experiment involves having an oocyte but
in this case an oocyte where the nucleus
has been removed okay so you're taking
enucleated
a site and you want to know if the
cytoplasm of this Oh site is somehow
special that would allow it to reprogram
the nucleus of a differentiated cell and
so you could suck up the nucleus of a
differentiated cell so somatic cells
another way to say differentiated the
somatic cell nucleus and the experiment
conceptually then is to just take this
somatic cell nucleus that you've sucked
up and inject it into an oocyte without
a nucleus and see if the cytoplasm of
this Oh site is somehow able to sort of
change the properties of the nucleus
such that it now is in an
undifferentiated state so you generate a
site now
with the somatic cell nucleus and the
question is whether this somatic cell
nucleus is capable of generating the
diversity of cell types that are
normally present in an organism so you
could then let this go and develop you
can let it develop into a blast do
blastula which I'm drawing here so you
could generate a blastula and this will
be a way to get embryonic stem cells
derived from sort of this type of
nucleus but you can also let it grow
into an entire organism but this
organism would be genetically identical
to whatever organism donated this
nucleus okay so because you're
duplicating an organism that is known as
reproductive cloning
this is reproductive cloning if you go
all the way to the organism I'll show
you just a little video on the nuclear
transfer you see now that this drilling
pipette is going to suck it drill a
little hole into the membrane you can
maybe see a little bit of the hole right
here at the next part it's talking about
this pipette here you can see a bit of
the hole and now the pipette is gonna go
in and remove the nucleus and if you
look carefully in the pipette you'll see
a line in the nucleus which are all the
chromosomes lined up so their nucleus is
going to be squirted out now because we
don't need it anymore
and there we have an enucleated egg now
the next step is to take a set of eggs
like that and I'll show you - and then
transfer into them and nucleus from
another kind of cell a fully
differentiated cymatics
so here the enucleated egg is set on the
side then it's held by this holding
pipette on the Left there's drilling the
little hole in the membrane here we go
in here comes the nucleus from the rice
these pipettes are operated with a piezo
electric device so you can't see it here
but it's like a little jackhammer going
very quickly like woody the woodpecker
getting in there - I don't know if I
would have used woody the woodpecker as
an analogy but that's basically the idea
okay so you can take a nucleus from a
somatic cell and Transplant it if you
will into an oocyte and then determine
whether you can get either a blastula or
an entire organism from that
differentiated cells nucleus so this is
one result from Sir John Gurdon and what
the experiment was in this case was to
take a sites or eggs from this wild-type
lavis frog and a transplant nuclei from
donor frogs that are ID by albino so you
can see this is an elegant experiment in
that you can sort of track the origin of
the nucleus because it's genetically
marked with this albino sort of
phenotype so that you're getting a
nuclei from you're getting some nuclei
from albino tadpoles so these are
differentiated cell nuclei and they're
transplanted into wild-type donor eggs
right so normally the wild-type frog
would reproduce frogs that look like it
that are non albino but in this
experiment our Gurdon and his lab were
able to get frogs that were albino okay
so these would be sort of clones of
whatever albino tadpoles they got the
nuclei from okay so you see in this case
it's the origin
the nucleus that is determining sort of
the the phenotype of these frogs so that
allowed them to show that the nucleus is
getting reprogrammed from this albino
tadpole and is able to still generate
all of the cell types present in a
normal organism yes Brett yes yeah yeah
so yeah and actually it was taking
unfertilized eggs which is the biggest
trick i think people had tried to do
this in frogs before and it failed
because they were using fertilized eggs
and there's something about sort of the
the state the oocyte development that
makes it better at reprogramming the
nucleus okay so that's with frogs so
that that experiment was actually done
in the late nineteen fifties published
in the early 1960s and so it took
another forty years or so for the first
mammal to be cloned and you guys
probably weren't even born yet but for
those of us who are older we remember
this because there was a big brouhaha
over Dolly the sheep which was the first
cloned mammal
I believe that's Dolly there so this is
I'm not sure which one is Dolly that
they're both the same type of sheep so
this was done by ian wilmut and his
group one thing i want to point out
about this is it's incredibly
inefficient okay if you look over here
right this dolly resulted from for over
400 sites having this sort of nuclear
transplant take place okay so it's not a
very efficient process and so that lack
of efficiency is due to the fact that
the nucleus is resisting getting
reprogrammed okay
this is a graph from one of John Gurdon
z' sort of he wrote a review article on
sort of reprogramming after he won the
Nobel Prize this is from that and what's
plotted is sort of the the frequency in
which transfers results in sort of a
differentiated organism and what's on
the x-axis is the stage of the cell
that's used to transplant okay and so
what you see is that over the course of
differentiation it gets harder and
harder for the nucleus to get
reprogrammed to create a sort of all the
cell types that are normally present in
an adult animal
okay so nuclei do become more restricted
in their ability to be reprogrammed over
development but the fact that any of
them are able to be reprogrammed
suggests that when they're we that
during differentiation there's not a
loss of gene content okay and John
Gurdon has done a lot to characterize
sort of the changes in the nucleus that
happened during differentiation which
sort of resist this reprogramming by the
no site cytoplasm
alright so mechanistically what's
happening well one big one of the people
who really showed what's going on there
is Shinya Yamanaka and what his work
shows is that you can take just a few
genes it turns out is four and you can
induce reprogramming by just expressing
these four genes in an adult
differentiated cell okay so in this case
in this case you have a differentiated
cell and what T initially used were
fibroblasts which are a type of
differentiated cell and what Yamanaka
showed is that you can express four
transcription factors one of them being
this factor here acht 4 which is
expressed in the inner cell mass and was
shown to be involved involved in sort of
maintaining pluripotency of these inner
mass inner cell mass cells so you could
take out 4 plus another transcription
factor which is important for
pluripotency plus 2 others and scénic
these are the 4 so these are all
transcription factors and what they
found is if you express these four
transcription factors in a
differentiated cell you could get it
revert to revert to a more pluripotent
state ok so this results in what is
known as induced pluripotent stem cells
or iPS cells for short okay and then
like embryonic stem cells all right here
these cells can give rise to different
cell types okay and so one of the goals
of this field of developmental biology
and and cell reprogramming is to use
this technology to replace cells that
are lost in patients so this is known as
regenerative medicine
and the idea of regenerator the theory
of regenerative medicine is to take ES
cells or induced pluripotent stem cells
from patients and to be able to culture
them in vitro so culture in vitro and
then to be able to direct these cultured
cells into different cell fates in order
to use these cells possibly to
transplant them back into an individual
where maybe these cell types are dying
okay so you could then differentiate
these cells using certain biochemical
signals that you can add to the media in
order to create different cell types
like neurons muscle babies skin okay one
example of this was shown by Shinya
Yamanaka where what they did was to take
human human fibroblast cells put them
back in the pluripotent state by
expressing those four factors and then
get these cells to differentiate into
cardio cardiac tissue so cardiac cells
here's a movie so these are from from
adult fibroblast cells but now you can
see they're beating like sort of like a
cardiac tissue would okay so these were
made into IPS stem cells cultured in
vitro and then directed into a cardiac
muscle fate okay so the goal would then
to be used these
and to transplant them back into back
into a patient such that if a patient
had let's say a neurodegenerative
disease and was lacking a certain type
of neuron you could then take cells
start them on the path to neuronal
development and then Transplant them
back into that patient and if these
cells are derived from the DNA of that
patient then there won't be transplant
rejection because what regulates
transplant rejection is the major
histocompatibility a complex locus and
it's polymorphic but if you're taking a
nucleus from the patient and then
causing the cells to differentiate in
vitro you're taking the exact same
you're taking clonal cells and putting
them back in the same patient such that
they won't be rejected
ideally all right now we want to try
something with the remainder of our time
I want a group all right everyone on
this side of the room over I want you
over here and everyone on this side of
the room I want you on this side over
here okay
maybe maybe you guys could go over here
so that we're more balanced we're gonna
have a little debate
[Music]
you can sit down it's okay be in a
position to talk to each other I want
you guys talking to each other that's
that's that was the goal of putting you
close together okay okay so in the past
couple weeks there has been a little bit
of a stir because researcher there's a
researcher in China who has claimed to
have made the first Jean edited baby
perhaps you have heard of this you
probably have because it's been all over
the news so I want you guys let's see I
want us to debate whether we should
whether sort of what are the advantages
or disadvantages of gene editing or
human cloning you could talk about both
and then I want you guys to be able to
kind of like present them to me I'll
write them down and we'll have a
discussion about it
near this discussion sort of outside
class I think it's really interesting
and it's going to be something that
you're gonna hear a lot about in the
coming year as I'm sure
you